nấu ăn dễ lắm chỉ cần dùng Sai cách item HOA
MasterChef nhờ unlock được công dụng ẩn của khay đĩa kèm vỉ
một món mà dùng được 10 kiểu
lướt TikTok là thấy xịn hơn dùng đúng hướng dẫn
AI nghĩ con mã khay đĩa kèm vỉ lọc dầu chỉ để lọc dầu
là hết vai nhưng lướt TikTok xong mới thấy dùng Sai cách
mới là chân ái
ngoài công dụng chính là lọc dầu với khay hướng bên dưới
netizen còn biến tấu đủ kiểu làm khay hấp
mini rack để nguội bánh
khay để co bày đồ ăn
lọc nước dùng thậm chí dùng làm khay sơ chế cực gọn
một item mà cân được từ nấu ăn đến decor
đúng kiểu một được 10 Cho hội tiêu tiền
thông Minh thiết kế tráng bạc nhìn xịn sò
đặt vào góc bếp thôi cũng nâng vai
nấu ăn liền quay múc bang cũng ngon mắt hơn hẳn
giá thì lại mềm xèo chưa tới một ly trà sữa
hiểu SAO netizen truyền Tay dần dần
thành hot item bếp núc 2.026 là không Sai